[Music]
a gigantic 900-pound 13-foot alligator
whoa who feasted on livestock in south
florida for 80 years geez wow
that's what we
is finally shot dead by a hunter no head
shot how big is it 13 900 pounds 13 feet
that's [ __ ] big they killed a monster
a dinosaur yeah a monster is is dead let
him whoa
let him i want to see him get bigger
oh my god dude
look at that
look at that boom headshot wow
that's huge it's crazy how this thing
lived 80 years like if he didn't kill
him would it would he kept on just
living yeah
so that that uh alligator was like it
was like the uh childhood legend of his
friend who's like man it's it's been
there since i was a kid but then it's
it's always been kind of like a nuisance
because it's eating all the cows and
stuff how what's the average size of an
alligator or like i mean now what's the
average lifespan of an alligator they
live how long a long time right like
hundreds of years like a like another
turtle okay and that's a pylon because
it's unfair because when you're hosting
it's hard what the [ __ ] what um american
alligators only live 30 to 50 years why
because someone kills them can you kill
this guy illegally is that true i
believe they were able to because it was
on private land i heard in florida
they're like considered a pest actually
because they're just crossing freeways
straight up farms in mississippi
mississippi oh alligators can live as
long as humans and average 70 years but
can be 100 okay oh can be honest this
was this was a special guy wow yeah
he did yoga or whatever yeah
this was a dinosaur dude
i mean it's like you're not people is
like peter going to get mad at him if
that he like turns that into like a
bunch of boots whoa i don't think so
totally gazelle
[Music]
but yeah they needed to do something
about it because it was just eating
everything if i killed a 13-foot
alligator i think i would want to hang
it in my house oh yeah he did he hung
the head in his house because that
thing's [ __ ] up that's pretty baller
dude i make a [ __ ] clock out of it
like captain hook dude
[Laughter]
and then just not dodge the mouth as it
comes down yeah yeah
yeah you know what i do is i carve the
inside out and make a [ __ ] canoe oh
that's cool
oh dude can i invite dante boss in my
house and take a picture in front of it
yeah
dude that would immediately bring the
legitimacy up so fast
dante bosco sign it take a picture make
it an nft
oh yeah and ask him to wear the outfit
too he's not gonna fit in so he's gonna
have a hard time getting into it
you're not interested in what kind of
gun you got this gator in the head let
me uh let me see that the wound i'm
gonna say
here it is doctor a bull a bull right oh
[ __ ] 56 cow yeah that sounds about right
what you think man
probably 50 cal
that wouldn't explode its head maybe 308
nah
i don't know what this means it's a
seven millimeter stw rifle because i
told you seven millimeter s t w s t w
yeah not s n w it's st
well i don't know let's see
lesson seven seven millimeter one of
these guys an ode to the seven
millimeter stw whoa one of those what
caliber does it take dry out kid
15 millimeter oh scary dude i don't know
much about guns i guess oh it's so it's
seven huh yeah
i don't know guns i know alligators now
yeah so they got i know i'm kind of gone
yeah you know well i know about my
friends
have you uh do you guys watch like um
barbecue videos and stuff because
there's this these guys the barbecue pit
boys they did a whole art alligator they
had a whole [ __ ] alligator it's good
and then they kept the head it kept the
tail they skinned the rest of the body
seasoned it they put it on a smoker
and um it reminded me of like the
filipino pig thing the whole thing right
but then obviously they took off the
skin of it
it was kind of funny because they try to
present it nice too they put like a
pineapple thing
and then yeah the apple didn't look nice
huh no it's a little like a monster
it's the whole thing that's a monster
eating a fruit salad does anybody here
eat an alligator
you know in a hot dog like in a
bratwurst yeah i had it like a almost
like a cutlet like a fried like a fried
cutlet it just tasted like fish chicken
i have a problem with eating predators
mostly because my wife made me a [ __ ]
oh
well uh
yeah they did to answer your question
they did use the gator meat it got used
for processing but the head uh homeboy
mounted it on his wall and uh and he's
not just some regular dude all right
this guy he's done a lot of [ __ ] he's
scratching ass he is like a hunter
hunter yeah like here here we go i'm
reading about that round so that's brown
for medium game which is like elk sized
animals he has racked up nine world
records and 36 state records for hunting
and fishing so he couldn't wait to shoot
the [ __ ] oh yeah he literally
said he was hunting it he said it's a
once in a lifetime opportunity when his
friend told him about this fabled
creature yeah he wanted to yeah yeah
seven millimeter is big it's it's bigger
than any other rounds that me and joe
have that's probably why we don't know
how thick are the bullets so it's like
two two three which is from like ars
like this 308 it's like a little bit
bigger this one was like this big 50
kills like
50 guys really but yeah the 50 cat would
have probably blown his head you
wouldn't be able to preserve it you've
been around have you been around 50 to
get shot yeah you feel like the [ __ ]
ripple if you're 20 feet away you feel
like go through your whole body earth
shakes yeah that's crazy from a 50 cal
yeah it's crazy how much does one bullet
cost what's the oh [ __ ] i don't know it
could be five to ten bucks my buddy has
one [ __ ]
yeah five to ten per bang bang per one
yeah yeah you can't even bang bang it's
just bad
[ __ ] there goes there goes [ __ ] two
cheeseburgers and super sized [ __ ]
fries and [ __ ] yeah carl's jr probably
because that's expensive [ __ ] so of
course when he posted his i know his
whole hunting result people got mad mad
of course horrors of course
right alligator i think that's fair game
but this guy has a whole like hunting
show i mean he operates dynamic outdoors
tv that's like a channel where literally
on hunting and fishing so yeah i think
it depends on what kind of hunting
because there's um
like invasive species that i think it's
good because it destroys the [ __ ]
ecosystem like the hogs in texas like
lions axis deer humans on earth humans
on earth giraffes elephants with ivory
tusks elephants with ivory types
billionaires pangolins for no reason
they got colvin baby seals baby seals uh
yeah what's up with people killing
babies seals you know what's coaching's
[ __ ] up what do you think what do you
think is
the biggest alligator on record is it
the dude that was walking by the [ __ ]
golf course
that thing is [ __ ] huge 20 feet 21
feet i say 20 feet or here we go i'll
rephrase that the biggest alligator to
ever be hunted
21 feet
18 feet 18 feet all right okay well
a guy named stokes oh wait no i'm sorry
a woman named mandy stokes that's wrong
that's wrong oh [ __ ] you don't think so
how's she gonna teabag it if she beats
it
she set the world record for the uh her
first gator hut in august of that year
which measured oh 2014 15 feet and nine
inches and it weighed a thousand and 11
pounds
yeah if they shoot him in the water i
wonder how they get him out oh yeah so
he shot this one in the water and they
had to go to the bottom of the lake and
pull it up whoa
one of those ones
yeah but he must be so hyped going to
get that thing no when he got oh man hey
what man got her into the sport huh uh
her husband john and brother-in-law
kevin
[Laughter]
i can't believe they they showed that
information so there's this thing where
nikki plays poker right and you play
poker but nikki plays poker then like if
she's at the table and guys are like you
know oh it's your husband plays or what
and she's like no he might he doesn't
play and they're like
well then who the [ __ ] got you into
poker
they get upset they can't handle that
she just plays poker and on and she
likes poker yeah like they're like every
time we go we went with the group and
then if there's girls in our group they
[ __ ] crush it because they just play
with the it's so much easier i didn't
realize like they just play with their
[ __ ] stereotypes
and then they're just they play stupid
bimbo they breaking that money
and then i'm like dude [ __ ] you man like
what what is that what is that again
is that is that red is that a square
oh you have one
all in i guess
[Laughter]
legit and it works that's how nikki
plays sometimes only if yeah if the
other guy's a dumbass probably huh yeah
well yeah she'll play she'll play the
room though but yeah it's so funny it's
[ __ ] amazing dude i would love to
watch her play it's fun i actually sat
there one time for five hours to watch
it because i was so fascinated plus i
was learning the game and yeah it's like
playing mafia it's interesting yeah when
you're in it your heart's like
you ever see people get like visibly
upset when nikki's playing with him yes
they get tilted because we're losing to
a little lady it's crazy it's [ __ ]
gross
you've seen it well i've seen it yeah
multiple times but like people just get
angry it's gambling yeah for the most
part though i like the poker room it's
different from blackjack i think
blackjack has the most degens and the
most like angriest players yeah but they
can never believe it they're always like
your husband oh come on your husband he
doesn't play what's he doing here you
said he's here and she's like he's just
you see the older dudes though yeah like
the younger guys they just play and then
they're usually like so introverted and
nerdy that they just don't give a [ __ ]
like i've seen one time a guy playing
poker while he has his laptop open and
he's playing like 10 different poker
like tables yeah i'm not i'm not kidding
i've seen that [ __ ] too it's crazy
that's enormous it's fun to stay on the
table dude like they have good [ __ ]
food like don't bust out a whole prime
rib and you could just be eating that
[ __ ] they'll be like sir oh yeah okay
massages too
massage ladies what don't bring the
[ __ ] chair and your face is in the
donut and you can see what's going on in
their [ __ ] massager in the background
yeah i mean one of those cats like you
know
whatever he's getting massaged by this
chick that's great dude that's great
it's kind of like that it's a whole
culture dude it's a whole stay there for
like eight hours 12 hours just stay
there that's true the longest i've
played was uh a little over 48 hours no
sleep whoa
48 out you didn't get sleepy i hit up
six poker rooms because my favorite
thing to do in vegas was um you go there
like in the middle of the night
because there's no traffic right and
then you just play until it's time to
check in
so like yeah so then so then when you go
with your friends it's kind of like oh
let's keep playing because as soon as
you get there you just want to play play
play right and then it's like ah let's
just keep going and then it's like 32
hours oh well we're not gonna [ __ ]
sleep in the morning wake up in the
morning we're gonna mess it up so let's
just stay up
and then you go like that and then
before you know it it's two days
straight i did this because uh before
you know it it's some days straight
and i wasn't on meth or anything too so
it was don't you don't you assume
anthony no i was just clarifying because
i it just sounded i don't know odd but i
was so bummed you assumed he wasn't
doing math because this is the second
time i missed new year's because i did
the same thing where you get there
excited you just play you get there
early because you think like i'm gonna
beat the crowd right so you're already
there for two days straight and then you
can't take it anymore and you crash
before the fireworks go out
and then i did that two times
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you